the direction ufc is going you see kobe
mazvidal counter
dustin some of the smack talking ways
that's going on how they talk trash to
each other part of it is a show
is there a line one shouldn't cross when
it comes on to smack talking because
when you guys were doing you know who
was the biggest smack talker when you
were in your 20s
uh uh
who would you say was the biggest smack
talker would you say
uh maybe it wasn't even in your class
was there anybody they said this guy
wouldn't stop talking trash non-stop
this is an interesting interesting
question that you bring um
for me
uh i know that it's a
a mental warfare especially in fighting
because we don't play games the outcome
of a of a loss or a win it can change
your life and i'm not talking about
physical injuries i'm talking about
money you know you you win a lot more
money and you gain a lot more
opportunity opportunities if you win
than if you lose it's crazy the outcome
is he have a
profound effect on an individual and his
is surrounding
therefore
knowing this
there is no line to cross and i know
some fighter will cross that line
me you can say whatever you want to me
maybe because of my experience with
bullying i'm used to put on a mask and a
shield on me so it comes and it deflect
or it goes to one here and it goes out
no problem
however if you start talking [ __ ] about
my my family now is different problem so
that's why
i knowing this about myself i always
deflected family question like stuff
like oh
like like like father or like everything
family i don't talk about it nobody
knows about me it's the thing that i'm
the most proud of but is my is is my
treasure
and i'm in the fighting game it's
different game than basketball yeah and
people will try to make you derail they
may try to make you lose your mind and i
can give you example of
that
sugary leonard against roberto duran
when they fought in montreal
i believe
that ray leonard is a much better boxer
than than rubber toads around i mean i
mean
at this level it's it's very close but i
believe leonard is better but when they
fought in montreal
juran insulted the wife of
of uh sugary leonard leonard goes crazy
he wanted to show that he's a man so he
stood up and he changed the way he
fought because
he became emotional
when conor mcgregor won the first fight
against jose aldo same thing
he became jose aldo became emotional he
wanted to he he became enraged tried to
give him he never did that he leaped
forward like crazy tried to knock him
out with one punch mcgregor is an
amazing counter puncher 12 seconds
finish same thing with khabib with conor
mcgregor tried to do the same thing with
kevi talking
about his religion yes his religion is
dead and stuff like that
so some fighter will will cross that
line that's why i never exposed my
family never
every interview we're never gonna you
know what i always deflected deflection
would make this try to get into your
skin nick was uh uh remember that one
time you guys had an exchange which i
can say what are you talking about
they don't have the information okay
they don't have the data to get on their
name ask him they cannot give it i never
make that available to them i never make
that i never
showcase this part of my life because
it's the part of my life that i'm the
most proud of
is my treasure that the mo i'm talking
about all my achievement my my career is
this is nothing
but but i never exposed this because to
protect me yeah because i'm i'm in that
business it's a hard business and it's
hardcore business but i don't want that
part of me being exposed so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]